What can you do for loss of smell after a viral infection?
So that has been a common issue with the COVID viral infection. It's a common issue with a lot
of different viral infections. Some of the things that you could do to help improve that
is there are some supplements that can help stimulate neural growth if there's damage to neurons
themselves. But things that are going to decrease inflammation, I think, are going to be your best thing.
I would think of antihistamine type nutrition. We have a product called clear histamine scavenger
which covers a lot of the histamine checkpoints because not just solely histamine that causes that
inflammation. So that would be a good product to think about. It's difficult. So viruses are
difficult to deal with because there's argument whether they're truly living organisms
or there's just a lot of argument and misunderstand knowledge, let's say, lack of knowledge that we have
with viruses. A lot of things are hypotheses about what a virus is and how they function
and what they could do to our body. Like I said with the Herpes virus, seemingly it's people have
tried everything and they seemingly can't get rid of them. All they do is knock you to tell them to
keep it in a state where it's not given it opportunity to flourish. So they are difficult. That's
where a lot of people use RIF technology to help with viruses and bacterial infection.
We saw a big uptick in the purchase of RIF technology in this last quote-unquote pandemic that we
had because it was a great tool to use to keep your family healthy when there are thoughts of
different infections, thoughts of different pandemics and possible new pandemics coming down the road.
All right, we're happy to write in your house can be extremely beneficial. But again,
there is no magic cure and RIF certainly isn't a magic cure for any of these things either,
so but I would certainly think frequency technology is just another piece that you can add to the